Pour le découvrir, j'ai étudié de gens que j'appelle « originaux ».
Les originaux sont non-conformistes,
des gens qui n'ont pas seulement de nouvelles idées
mais qui agissent pour les réaliser.
Il y a des gens se détachent et prennent la parole.
Les originaux sont source de créativité et de changement dans le monde.
Ceux sur lesquels vous voulez parier.
Et ils ne ressemblent pas à ce que j'avais imaginé.
Je veux vous montrer trois choses que j'ai apprises
pour reconnaître les originaux
et leur ressembler un peu plus.
La première raison pour laquelle j'ai laissé passer Warby Parker
était qu'ils ont été très lents à décoller.
Vous êtes tous intimement familiers avec l'esprit d'un procrastinateur.
Je dois vous dire une chose.
Je suis l'opposé. Je suis un précrastinateur.
Oui, c'est un mot.
Vous connaissez la panique ressentie quelques heures avant une échéance
et que vous n'avez rien fait.
Je le ressens quelques mois en avance.
(Rires)
Cela a commencé tôt :
enfant, je prenais très au sérieux tous les jeux Nintendo.
Je me réveillais à 5 heures du matin,
commençais à jouer et n'arrêtais que lorsque le jeu était fini.
Cela a tellement dégénéré qu'un journal local est venu
et a écrit un article sur le côté sombre de Nintendo, en me citant comme exemple.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Depuis, j'ai échangé des dents contre des cheveux.
(Rires)
Mais cela m'a été utile à l'université
car j'ai fini ma thèse quatre mois avant la date limite.
J'en étais fier, jusqu'à il y a quelques années.
J'ai eu une étudiante du nom de Jihae qui est venu me voir et m'a dit :
« J'ai mes idées les plus créatives quand je procrastine. »
J'ai dit : « C'est mignon, où sont les quatre devoirs que tu me dois ? »
(Rires)
C'était une de nos étudiantes les plus créatives
et c'est une choses que je dois tester en tant que psychologue organisationel.
Je l'ai défiée de me donner des données.
Elle va dans quelques entreprises,
fait remplir des enquêtes aux gens sur leur façon de procrastiner.
Puis elle demande aux patrons de noter leur créativité et leur inventivité.
Et, bien sûr, les précrastinateurs comme moi,
qui se précipitent et font tout en avance
sont estimés moins créatifs
que ceux qui procrastinent modérément.
Je veux savoir ce qu'il arrive aux procrastinateurs chroniques.
Elle m'a dit : « Je ne sais pas. Ils n'ont pas rempli mes enquêtes. »
(Rires)
Voici nos résultats.
Vous voyez que les personnes qui attendent la dernière minute
sont trop occupées à s'amuser pour avoir de nouvelles idées.
A l'autre opposé, les personnes qui foncent
sont dans une telle frénésie anxieuse qu'elles n'ont pas de pensées originales.
Il y a un point idéal où les originaux semblent se trouver.
Pourquoi ?
Peut-être que les originaux ont juste de mauvaises habitudes de travail
et que procrastiner ne cause pas la créativité.
Pour le découvrir, nous avons créé des expériences.
Nous avons demandé aux gens de générer de nouvelles idées commerciales
puis des lecteurs indépendants
devaient évaluer leur créativité et utilité.
Et certains devaient faire la tâche immédiatement.
Certains, tirés aux hasard, devaient procrastiner
en jouant au démineur
pendant 5 ou 10 minutes.
Bien sûr, les procrastinateurs modérés
sont 16% plus créatifs que les deux autres groupes.
Démineur, c'est génial, mais ce n'est pas la déclencheur,
car si vous y jouez avant d'avoir connaissance de la tâche,
il n'y a pas de gain de créativité.
C'est uniquement quand on vous dit que vous allez travailler sur ce problème
et que, ensuite, vous procrastinez,
mais que la tâche est toujours active dans votre cerveau,
que vous incubez.
La procrastination vous donne le temps de considérer des idées divergentes,
de penser de façon non-linéaire, de faire des bonds imprévisibles.
Alors que nous terminions ces expériences,
je débutais un livre sur les originaux
et je me suis dit : « C'est le moment pour apprendre à procrastiner,
en écrivant un chapitre sur la procrastination. »
J'ai donc méta-procrastiné,
et comme tout précrastinateur qui se respecte,
je me suis levé tôt
et ai fait une liste d'étapes pour bien procrastiner.
(Rires)
Puis j'ai diligemment travaillé
pour atteindre mon but de ne pas progresser vers mon but.
J'écrivais le chapitre sur la procrastination
et, un jour, en plein milieu du chapitre,
j'ai arrêté en milieu de phrase
pour des mois.
C'était horrible.
Mais quand j'y suis revenu, j'avais de nouvelles idées.
Comme Aaron Sorkin disait :
« Vous parlez de procrastination, je parle de réflexion. »
Au passage, j'ai découvert
que de nombreux originaux de l'histoire étaient des procrastinateurs.
Prenez Léonard de Vinci.
Il a peint pendant 16 ans
sur la Joconde.
Il se sentait nul.
Il le dit dans son journal.
Mais certaines des pauses
ont transformé sa façon de modéliser la lumière
et ont fait de lui un meilleur peintre.
Qu'en est-il de Martin Luther King ?
La nuit précédant son plus grand discours,
la Marche sur Washington,
il a écrit jusqu'à plus de 3 heures du matin.
Assis dans le public, à attendre son tour de monter sur scène,
il prenait encore des notes et rayait des lignes.
Monté sur scène, après 11 minutes,
il laisse les notes préparées
pour prononcer quatre mots qui ont changé l'histoire :
« J'ai fait un rêve. »
Ce n'était pas prévu.
En repoussant la finalisation de son discours à la dernière minute,
il est resté ouvert à de nombreuses idées.
Puisque son discours n'était pas gravé dans le marbre,
il a pu improviser.
La procrastination est un vice en termes de productivité,
mais une vertu pour la créativité.
Chez de nombreux originaux, on voit
qu'ils sont rapides à commencer mais lents à finir.
C'est ce que j'ai loupé chez Warby Parker.
Alors qu'ils traînaient les pieds depuis 6 mois,
je leur ai dit :
« Beaucoup d'autres entreprises commencent à vendre des lunettes en ligne. »
Ils n'avaient plus l'avantage d'être les premiers.
Mais je ne réalisais pas qu'ils passaient ce temps-là
à trouver un moyen
de rendre les gens plus à l'aise.
Il s'avère que l'avantage qu'a le premier venu est un mythe.
Prenez une étude classique de catégories de plus de 50 produits,
comparez les premiers venus, créateurs du marché,
et les améliorateurs, faisant différent et mieux.
Les premiers venus ont un taux d'échec de 47%,
comparés à seulement 8% pour les améliorateurs.
Regardez Facebook, créant un média social
après Myspace et Friendster.
Et Google, attendant des années après Altavista et Yahoo.
Il est beaucoup plus simple d'améliorer l'idée d'un autre
que de créer quelque chose de nouveau.
J'en ai déduit que pour être original, pas besoin d'être premier,
il suffit d'être différent et meilleur.
Je n'ai pas refusé Warby Parker uniquement pour cette raison.
Ils avaient aussi beaucoup de doutes.
Ils avaient des plans de secours
et cela m'a fait douter de leur courage à être originaux,
car je m'attendais à ce que les originaux ressemblent à cela.
(Rires)
En apparence,
beaucoup d'originaux semblent confiants,
mais en coulisses,
ils ressentent les mêmes peurs et doutes que nous autres.
Ils le gèrent juste différemment.
Je vais vous montrer une illustration
du processus créatif pour la majorité d'entre nous.
(Rires)
Au cours de mes recherches, j'ai découvert deux types de doutes différents.
On peut douter de soi ou de l'idée.
Douter de soi paralyse.
Cela nous immobilise.
Mais douter de l'idée nous stimule.
Cela nous motive à tester, expérimenter, raffiner,
comme l'a fait MLK.
La clé de l'originalité
n'est qu'une question
d'éviter le fossé l'entre l'étape 3 et l'étape 4.
Au lieu de dire : « Je suis nul »,
dites : « Les premiers brouillons sont toujours nuls,
je n'y suis juste pas encore. »
Comment atteindre cela ?
Il s'avère qu'il y a un truc
lié à votre navigateur internet.
Vous pouvez prévoir votre performance et votre implication
en connaissant votre navigateur.
Certains n'aimeront pas les résultats de cette étude --
(Rires)
mais il y a des preuves que les utilisateurs de Firefox et Chrome
sont bien plus performants que ceux d'Internet Explorer et Safari.
Oui.
(Applaudissements)
Ils gardent également leur poste 15% plus longtemps.
Pourquoi ? Ce n'est pas un avantage technique.
Les quatre groupes de navigateurs ont la même vitesse de frappe
et les mêmes connaissances en informatique.
La question est comment vous obtenez le navigateur.
Si vous utilisez Internet Explorer ou Safari,
qui sont préinstallés sur votre ordinateur,
vous acceptez l'option par défaut qui vous est proposée.
Si vous vouliez Firefox ou Chrome, vous avez remis en question
cette option par défaut et cherché une autre option,
puis avez téléchargé un nouveau navigateur.
Certains se disent alors :
« Super, pour mieux faire mon boulot, je dois juste changer de navigateur ? »
(Rires)
Il est question d'être le genre de personnes
qui prend l'initiative de mettre en doute le par défaut
et cherche une meilleure option.
Si vous le faites bien,
vous vous ouvrirez à l'opposé du déjà vu.
Cela a un nom. Cela s'appelle : « vujàdé ».
(Rires)
« Vujàdé », c'est regarder quelque chose que vous avez souvent vu
et, soudainement, le voir autrement.
C'est un scénariste qui regarde un script de film
qui n'a pas eu de feu vert depuis plus de 50 ans.
Dans chaque version,
le personnage principal était une reine diabolique.
Mais Jennifer Lee a demandé le sens de cela.
Elle réécrit le premier acte,
transforme le méchant en un héros torturé
et « La Reine des Neiges » devient le plus grand succès au cinéma.
Derrière cela, il y a un message simple.
Si vous doutez, ne lâchez rien.
(Rires)
Qu'en est-il de la peur ?
Les originaux aussi ont peur.
Ils ont peur de l'échec,
mais ce qui les différencie de nous autres,
c'est qu'ils ont encore plus peur de ne pas essayer.
Ils savent que l'on peut échouer en lançant une entreprise qui fait faillite
ou en ne lançant pas d'entreprise.
Ils savent qu'à long terme,
nos plus grands regrets ne sont pas nos actions
mais nos inactions.
Les choses que l'on aimerait changer, d'après la science,
sont les risques non pris.
Elon Musk m'a dit récemment qu'il ne s'attendait pas au succès de Tesla.
Il était certain que les premiers lancements de SpaceX
n'orbiteraient pas, et reviendraient encore moins,
mais c'était trop important pour ne pas essayer.
Pour beaucoup d'entre nous, quand nous avons une idée,
nous n'essayons même pas.
Mais j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous.
Vous n'allez pas être jugés sur vos mauvaises idées.
Beaucoup pensent que c'est le cas.
Prenez différentes industries
et questionnez les gens sur leurs plus grandes idées et suggestions,
85% d'entre eux sont restés silencieux au lieu de parler.
Ils avaient peur d'avoir honte, d'avoir l'air idiot.
Mais devinez quoi ? Les originaux ont beaucoup de mauvaises idées,
des tonnes en fait.
Prenez le gars qui a inventé cela.
Cela vous importe-t-il qu'il ait inventé une poupée si flippante
qu'elle effrayait les enfants et les adultes ?
Non. Vous célébrez Thomas Edison pour l'invention de l'ampoule.
(Rires)
Prenez plusieurs secteurs,
les plus grands originaux sont ceux qui échouent le plus,
car ils essayent le plus.
Prenez les compositeurs classiques, les meilleurs des meilleurs.
Pourquoi certains ont-ils plus de pages d'encyclopédie que d'autres
et ont des compositions plus enregistrées ?
Un des meilleurs indicateurs
est le volume brut de compositions générées.
Plus vous créez, plus vous êtes diversifié
et plus vous avez de chances d'avoir quelque chose de vraiment original.
Mêmes les trois icônes de la musique classique -- Bach, Beethoven, Mozart --
ont dû générer des centaines de compositions
pour créer quelques chefs-d’œuvre.
Vous vous demandez peut-être :
comment ce gars est-il devenu génial sans en faire beaucoup ?
Je ne sais pas comment a fait Wagner.
Mais pour la majorité d'entre nous, pour être plus originaux,
nous devons générer plus d'idées.
Les fondateurs de Warby Parker, en cherchant un nom pour leur entreprise,
avaient besoin d'un nom sophistiqué, unique, sans connotation négative
pour créer une marque
et ils ont testé plus de 2 000 possibilités
avant de trouver
Warby et Parker.
En résumé, les originaux
ne sont pas si différents de nous.
Ils ont peur et doutent. Ils procrastinent.
Ils ont de mauvaises idées.
Et parfois, ce n'est pas malgré mais grâce à ces qualités
qu'ils réussissent.
Quand vous voyez ces choses, ne commettez la même erreur que moi.
Ne les éliminez pas.
Et si c'est vous, ne vous considérez pas nul.
Sachez qu'un départ rapide et une arrivée lente
peuvent améliorer votre créativité,
que vous pouvez vous motiver en doutant de vos idées
et en étreignant la peur de l'échec,
et que vous avez besoin de beaucoup de mauvaises idées pour quelques bonnes.
Être original n'est pas facile,
mais je n'ai aucun doute à ce sujet :
c'est la meilleure façon d'améliorer le monde qui nous entoure.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)